let's go back to Big Willie for a second
because you don't purse 50th birthday he
jumps out of a helicopter over the Grand
Canyon and a bungee jump I would never
do that absolutely
that is crazy your husband won't let you
I know for a fact fine Jada
pinkett-smith for some reason said ok to
will but you better believe she was
scared it's one of those moments when
you you attest is true your faith is
truly tested when I saw him flying
outside of the helicopter that's when I
got a little nervous but you know I was
like he's covered he's good you know and
and I was really strong in that strong
doesn't begin to cover it
Jada is a force of nature case in point
we were with her today at the Will and
Jada Smith Family Foundation and careers
and entertainment event where she hosted
a fireside chat for 500 LA area high
school students data launched the
initiative to expose kids to career
opportunities in the entertainment
business I've had people tell me some of
the crazy things the craziest age your
accent have an East Coast accents you'll
never make it in this business it's like
really okay a lot of times the students
have come out and be like thank you so
much I had no idea that that was
available to me this mom an advocate is
a very busy lady
she's also bringing her very candid
read.table talk back for a second season
with some very special guests will is
our first guest we're talking about
issues loving marriage we're talking
about this all kind stuff it's gonna be
it's gonna be a really great dear
[Music]
[Applause]